the following is a conversation with BR
install stroke he's the creator of C++
programming language that after 40 years
is still one of the most popular and
powerful languages in the world it's
focused on fast stable robust code
underlies many of the biggest systems in
the world that we have come to rely on
as a society if you're watching this on
YouTube for example many of the critical
backend components of YouTube are
written in C++ same goes for Google
Facebook Amazon Twitter most Microsoft
applications Adobe applications most
database systems and most physical
systems that operate in the real world
like cars robots rockets that launches
into space and one day when landis on
Mars C++ also happens to be the language
that I used more than any other in my
life I've written several hundred
thousand lines of C++ source code of
course lines of source code don't mean
much but they do give hints of my
personal journey through the world of
software I've enjoyed watching the
development of C++ as a programming
language leading up to the big update in
a standard in 2011 and those that
followed in 1417 and told me the new C++
20 standard hopefully coming out next
year this is the artificial intelligence
podcast if you enjoy it subscribe I knew
to give it five stars and iTunes
supported on patreon or simply connect
with me on Twitter Alex Friedman spelled
Fri D ma a.m. and now here's my
conversation with Bjorn straw stroke
what was the first program you've ever
written do you remember it was my second
year in university first year of
computer science and it was an alcohol
60 I calculated the shape of super lips
and then connected points on the on the
perimeter
creating star patterns it was with a
with a wedding on paper printer and I
was in college university yeah yeah I
learned to program the second year in
university and what was the first
programming language if I may ask it
this way that you fell in love with I I
think I'll call 60 and after that I
remember I remember snowboard
I remember Fortran didn't fall in love
with that I remember Pascal didn't fall
in love with that it all gotten away of
me and then I just covered a simpler and
that was much more fun and from there I
went to micro micro code so you were
drawn to the you found the low level
stuff beautiful I went through a lot of
languages and then I spent significant
time in in a simpler and micro code that
was sort of the first really profitable
things I paid for my Master's actually
and then I discovered Simula which was
absolutely great Simula simulation of
Albert 60 done primarily for simulation
but basically they invented up to Tory
into programming at inheritance and
runtime polymorphism when they were
while they were doing it and that was a
language that taught me that you could
have the sort of the problems of a
program grow with size of the program
rather than with the square of the size
of
program that is you can actually module
arise very nicely and that that that was
a surprise to me it was also a surprise
to me that a stricter type system than
Pascal's was helpful whereas Pascal's
type system got in my way all the time
so you need a strong type system to
organize your code well which has to be
extensible and flexible let's get into
the details a little bit what kind of if
you remember what kind of type system to
Pascal have what type system typing
system did the Algol 60 have basically
Pascal was sort of the simplest language
that Niklaus yet could define that
served the needs of Niklaus Viet at the
time and it has a sort of our highly
moral tone to it that is if you can say
it in Pascal it's good and if you can't
it's not so good whereas
Simula large is basically to build your
own type system so instead of trying to
fit yourself into Niklaus pierce'sworld
Christ knew God's language and Orion
dance language allowed you to build your
own so it's sort of close to the
original idea of you you you build a
domain-specific language as a matter of
fact what you build is a set of types
and relations among types that allows
you to express something that suitable
for an application the when you say
types the stuff you're saying has echoes
of object-oriented programming
Kjetil they invented it every language
that uses the word class for type is a
descendant of Simula directly or
indirectly Christ knew gone orientale
were mathematicians and they didn't
think in terms of type C but they
understood sets and classes of elements
and so they caught their types classes
and basically in C++ as in similar
classes are user defined type so can you
try the impossible task and give a brief
history of programming languages from
your perspective so we started with
Algol 60 Simula Pascal but that's just
the 60s and seven I can try
the most sort of interesting and major
improvement of programming languages was
Fortran the first Fortran because before
that all code was written for a specific
machine and each specific machine had a
language a simply language or cross
embro or some extension of that idea but
it you are writing for a specific
machine in the term in the language of
that machine and
parker's and his team at IBM built a
language that would allow you to to
write what you really wanted that is you
can write it in a language that was
natural for people now these people
happen to be engineers and physicists so
the language I came out was somewhat
unusual for the rest of the world but
basically they said formula translation
because they wanted to have the
mathematical formulas translated into
the machine and as a side effect
they got portability because now they
are writing in the terms that the humans
used and the way humans thought and then
they had a program that translated it
into the machines needs and that was new
and that was great and it's something to
remember we want to raise the language
to the human level but we don't want to
lose the efficiency so and the last
first step towards the human that was
the first step and of course they were
very particular kind of humans business
people MIT is different so they got
COBOL instead and etc etc and simular
came out no let's not go to simulate yet
let's go to Al Gore Fortran didn't have
at the time the notions of not a precise
notion of type not a precise notion of
scope not a set of translation phases
that was what we have today
lexical since heck semantics it was sort
of a bit of a model in the early days
but hey they're just done the biggest
breakthrough and history of programming
right so you can't criticize them for
not having gotten all the technical
details right so we got alcohol that was
very pretty and most people in Commerce
and science considered it useless
because it was not flexible enough and
it wasn't efficient enough and etc etc
but that was the breakthrough from a
technical point of view then similar
came along to make that idea more
flexible and you could define your own
types and that's where where I got very
interested first Nicole was the main
idea and behind Simula I was late 60s
this was late 60s was a visiting
professor in Oz and so I learned
object-oriented programming by sitting
around well in theory discussing with
with Christ Mughal but Kristin once you
get started and then full flow it's very
hard to get a word in edgeways where
you're just listed so it was great I
learned it from them not to romanticize
the notion but it seems like a big leap
to think about object-oriented
programming it's really a leap of
abstraction it's yes and was that as big
and beautiful of a leap as it seems from
now in retrospect I was in an obvious
one at the time it was not obvious and
many people have tried to do something
like that
and most people didn't come up with
something as wonderful as similar lots
of people got their PhDs and made their
careers out of forgetting about Simula
or never knowing it for me the key idea
was basically I could get my own types
and that's the idea that goes for a
lines of C++ where I can get better
types and more flexible types and more
efficient types but it's still the
fundamental idea when I want to write a
program I want to write it with my types
that is appropriate to my problem and
under the constraints that I'm under
with hardware software environment etc
and that's that's the key idea people
picked up on
hierarchy is in the virtual functions
and the inheritance and that was only
part of it it was an interesting and
major part and still a major part and a
lot of graphic stuff but it was not the
most fundamental it it was when you
wanted to relate one type to another you
don't want the more to be independent
that the classical example is that you
don't actually want to write city
simulation with vehicles where you say
well if it's a buy signal to write the
code for turning a bicycle to the left
if it's a normal car turn right a normal
car way if it's a fire engine and right
the fire engine way da da da da da you
get these big case statements and
bunches of if statement and such
instead you tell the other the base
class that that's the Viacom saying turn
turn left the way you want to and this
is actually a real example they they
used it to simulate and optimize the
emergency the emergency services for
somewhere Norway
back in the 60s Wow so this was one of
the early examples for why you needed
inheritance and and you needed runtime
polymorphism because you wanted to
handle this set of vehicles in a
manageable way you you you can't just
rewrite your code each time a new kind
of vehicle comes along yeah that's a
beautiful powerful idea and of course
that it stretches through your work who
C++ as we'll talk about but I think you
structured it nicely
what other breakthroughs came along in
the history of programming languages
they if we were to tell the history in
that way obviously I'm bitter telling
the part of the history that that is the
path I'm on as opposed to all the path
yeah you skipped the hippy
John McCarthy and Lisp or my favorite
languages but listen what Lisp is not
one of my favorite language yes it's
obviously important it's obviously
interesting lots of people write code in
it and then they rewrite it into C or
C++ when they want to go to production
yes it's in the world
I met which are constrained by
performance reliability issues
deployability cost of hardware I I don't
like things to be too dynamic it is
really hard to write a piece of code
that's perfectly flexible that you can
also deploy on a small computer and that
you can also put in say a telephone
switch in Bogota what's the chance if
you get an error and you find yourself
in the debugger that the telephone
switch in pockets are on late Sunday
night has a programmer around right
their chance is zero and so a lot of
things I think most about can't afford
that flexibility and I'm quite aware
that maybe 70 80 percent of all code are
not under the kind of constraints I'm
interested in but somebody has to do the
job I'm doing because you have to get
from these high level flexible languages
to the hardware the stuff that lasts for
10 20 30 years is robust
yeah operates under very constrained
conditions yes absolutely that's right
and it's fascinating and beautiful in
its own way it's C++ is one of my
favorite languages and so is Lisp
so I can I can embody two for different
reasons as as a programmer I understand
why it is popular and I can see the
beauty of the ideas and similarly with
this more talk
it's just know this relative thank it
it's not as relevant in my world and by
the way I distinguish between those and
the functional languages where I go to
things like ml and Hesco different
different kind of languages they have a
different kind of huge in there very
interesting and I actually try to learn
from all the languages I encounter to
see what is layer that would make
working on the kind of problems I'm
interested in with the kind of
constraints that that I'm interested in
what can actually be done better because
we can surely do better than we do today
you've you've said that it's good for
any professional programmer to know at
least five languages speaking about a
variety of languages that you've taken
inspiration from and you've listed the
yours as being at least at the time C++
obviously Java Python Ruby and
JavaScript can you first of all update
that list modify it if you don't have to
be constrained to just five but can you
describe what you picked up also from
each of these languages how you see them
as inspirations for even you're working
with C++ this is a very hard question to
answer
so about languages you should know
languages I I reckon I knew about
twenty-five or there abouts when I did
C++ it was easier than those days
because the languages were smaller and
you didn't have to learn a whole
programming environment and such to do
it you you could learn the language
quite easily and it's good to learn so
many languages and I imagine just like
with natural language for communication
there's different paradigms that emerge
in all of them yeah that there's
commonalities and so on so I picked fire
out of a head so far ahead obviously
well the important thing that the number
is not one that's right it's like I
don't like I mean if you're mono clot
you are likely to think that your own
culture is the only ones peer is
everybody else's a good learning of a
foreign language and a foreign culture
is important it helps you think and be a
better person with programming languages
you become a better programmer better
designer with the second language now
once you've got to the wage of five is
not that long it's the second one that's
most important and then when I had to
pick five I sort of thinking what kinds
of languages are there well there's a
really low level stuff it's good it's
actually good to know machine code movie
very still sorry even today even today
the C++ optimizer is right there a
machine code than I do
yes but I don't think I could appreciate
them if I actually didn't understand
machine code and machine architecture at
least in in my position I have to
understand a bit of it because you mess
up the cash and you're off in
performance by a factor of a hundred
right shouldn't be that if you are
interested in higher performance or the
size of the computer you have to deploy
so so I would go there's a simpler
I used to mention C but these days going
low-level is not actually what gives you
the performance it is to express your
ideas so cleanly that you can think
about it and the optimizer can
understand what you're up to
my favorite way of optimizing these days
is to throw out the clever bits and see
if it's dawn runs fast and sometimes it
runs faster so I need the abstraction
mechanisms or something like C++ to
write compact high-performance code
there was a beautiful keynote by Jason
Turner
the CPP con a couple of years ago where
he decided he was going to program pong
on Motorola 6800 I think it was and he
says well this is relevant because it
looks like a microcontroller it has
specialized hardware it has not very
much memory and it's relatively slow and
so he shows in real time how he writes
pong starting with fairly
straightforward low-level stuff
improving his abstractions and what he's
doing he's writing C++ and it translate
into
in 286 assembler which you can do with
playing and you can see it in real-time
it's the compiled explora which you can
use on the web and then he wrote a
little program that translated 86
assembler into
Motorola has simpler and so he types and
you can see this thing in real time
while you can see it in real time and
even if you can't read the assembly code
you can just see it
his code gets better the code the
assembler gets Kimura he increases the
abstraction level uses C++ 11 as it were
better this code gets clean that gets
easier maintain the code shrinks and it
keeps shrinking and I could not in any
reasonable amount of time write that a
simpler as good as the compiler
generated from really a quite nice
modern C++ and I'll go as far as to say
the the thing that looked like C was
significantly uglier and and smaller
when it becames
and and larger when it became machine
code so what the the abstractions that
can be optimized important I would love
to see that kind of visualization larger
code bases yeah there might be blood a
few can't show a larger code base in a
one-hour talk and to have it fit on
screen right so that C is if you love so
my two languages would be machine code
and C++ and then I think you can learn a
lot from the functional languages so pig
has pralaya male I don't care which I
think actually you you'll you'll learn
the same lessons of expressing
especially mathematical notions really
clearly and having the type system
that's really strict and then you should
probably have a language for sort of
quickly churning out something you could
pick JavaScript you could pick Python
you could pick Ruby really make of
JavaScript in general so you kind of
you're talking in the Platonic sense of
all languages about what they're good at
what their philosophy design is but
there's also a large user base behind
each of these languages and they use it
in the way
maybe it wasn't really designed for
that's right javascript is used way
beyond I probably put hooks design for
it let let me say it this way when you
build a tool you do not know how it's
going to be used you try to improve the
tool by looking at how it's being used
and when people cut their fingers off
and try and stop that from happening but
really you have no control over how
something is used so I'm very happy and
proud of some of the things he plus
plaus being used at and some of the
things I wish people wouldn't do Bitcoin
mining being my favorite example uses as
much energy as Switzerland and mostly
serves criminals yeah but back to back
to the languages I actually think that
having JavaScript run in the browser
what was was an enabling thing for a lot
of things yes you could have done it
better but people were trying to do it
better they were using proof sort of
more principles language designs but
they just couldn't do it right and the
non professional programmers that write
or lots of that code just couldn't
understand them so it did
amazing job for what it was it's not the
prettiest language and I don't think it
ever will be the prettiest language but
that's not be bigots here so what was
the origin story of C++ you you
basically gave a few perspectives of
your inspiration of object-oriented
programming that's you had a connection
with C in performance efficiency was an
important thing you were drawn to
efficiency and reliability reliability
you have to get both what
what's reliability I I really want my
telephone calls to get through and I
want the quality of what I am talking
coming out with the other end the other
end might be in London or wherever so
and you don't want the system to be
crashing if you're doing a bank here is
you must not crash it might be your your
bank account that is in trouble there's
different constraints like in games it
doesn't matter too much if there's a
crash nobody dies and nobody gets ruined
but I am interested in the combination
of performance partly because of sort of
speed of things being done part of being
able to do things that is necessary to
do to have reliable energy of larger
systems if you spend all your time
interpreting a simple function call you
are not going to have enough time to do
proper signal processing to get the
telephone calls to sound right I know
that or you have to have 10 times as
many computers and you can't afford your
phone anymore it's a ridiculous idea in
the modern world because we have solved
all of those problems I mean they keep
popping up in different ways as we
tackle bigger and bigger problems
efficiency remains always an important
aspect but you have to think about
efficiency not just as speed but as an
enabler to
things and women thinks it enables is
this reliability is dependability you
won when I press the pedal the brake
pedal of a car it is not actually
connect it directly to to anything but a
computer that computer better work let's
talk about reliability just a little bit
so modern cars have ECU's millions of
lines of code Mme
so this is certainly especially true of
autonomous vehicles where some of the
aspects of the control or driver
assistance systems that steer the car
the key panel and so on so how do you
think you know I talk to regulators
people in government who are very
nervous about testing the safety of
these systems of software ultimately
software that makes decisions that could
lead to fatalities so how do you how do
we test software systems like these
first of all safety like performance and
like security is a systems property
people tend to look at one part of a
system at a time and saying something
like this is secure that's all right I
don't need to do that yeah that piece of
code is secure I'll buy your operator
right if you want to have reliability if
you want to have performance if you want
to have security you have to look at the
whole system I did not expect you to say
that but that's very true
yes I'm dealing with one part of the
system and I want my part to be really
good but I know it's not the whole
system furthermore if making an
individual part perfect may actually not
be the best way of getting the highest
degree of reliability and performance
and such the spumone says super cross
type say not type safe you can break it
sure I can break anything that runs on a
computer I may not go through your type
system
if I wanted to break into your computer
I'll probably try SQL injection and it's
very true if you think about safety or
even reliability at its system level
especially when a human being is
involved it's starts becoming hopeless
pretty quickly in terms of proving that
something is safe to a certain level
yeah there's so many variables it's so
complex well let's get back to something
we can talk about and it actually makes
some progress on yes we look at C++
programs and we can try and make sure
the crash less often the way you do that
is largely by simplification it is not
the first step is to simplify the code
have less code have code that are less
likely to go wrong it's not by runtime
testing everything it is not by big test
frameworks that you're using yes we do
that also but the first step is actually
to make sure that when you want to
express something you can express it
directly in code rather than going
through endless loops and convolutions
in your head before it gets down the
code that if if the way you are thinking
about a problem is not in the code there
is a missing piece that's just in your
head and the code you can see what it
does but it cannot see what you thought
about it unless you have expressed
things directly when you express things
directly you can maintain it
it's these years to find errors is
easier to make modifications it's
actually easier to test it and lo and
behold it runs faster
and therefore you can use a smaller
number of computers which means there's
less hardware that could possibly break
so I think the key here is
simplification but it has to be to use
the Einstein code as simple as possible
and no simpler not simpler well there
are other areas with under constraints
where you can be simpler than you can be
in C++ but in the domain I'm dealing
with
that's the simplification I'm after so
how do you inspire or ensure that the
Einstein level simplification is reached
so okay can you do code review can you
look at code is there if I gave you the
code for the Ford f-150 and said here is
this a mess or is this okay is it
possible to tell is it possible to
regulate an experienced developer can do
it code and see if it smells you know
I'm mixed metaphors deliberately yes the
the point is that it is hard to generate
something that is really obviously clean
and can be appreciated but you can
usually recognize when you haven't
reached that point and so if I I've
never looked at me if 150 code so I
wouldn't know but but I know what I
ought to be looking for there I'll be
looking for some tricks that correlates
with bugs and elsewhere and I have tried
to formulate rules for what what good
code looks like and the current version
of that is called the C++ core
guidelines
one thing people should remember is
there's what you can do in a language
and what you should do in a language you
have lots of things that is necessary in
some context but not another's as things
that exist just because there's 30 year
old code out there and you can't get rid
of it but you can't have rules it says
when you create it try and follow these
rules this does not create good programs
by themselves but it limits the damage
and off for mistakes it limits the
possibilities of the mistakes and
basically we are trying to say what is
it that a good programmer does at the
fairly simple level of where you use the
language and how you use it now I can
move all the rules for chiseling in my
marble it doesn't mean that somebody who
follows all of those rules can do a
masterpiece by Machine Angelo
that is there something else to write a
good program just is there something
else to create important work of art
that is there's some kind of inspiration
understanding gift but we can approach
the sort of technical the the
craftsmanship level of it the the the
famous painters the famous cultures was
among other things
superb craftsmen they could express
their ideas using their tools very well
and so these days I think what I'm doing
what a lot of people are doing we're
still trying to figure out how it is to
use our tools very well for a really
good piece of code you need a spark of
inspiration and you can't
I think regulate that you you cannot say
that I'll take a picture
only I'll buy your picture only if
you're at least then go there are things
you can regulate but not the inspiration
I think that's quite beautifully put it
is true that there is there's an
experienced programmer when you see code
that's inspired that's like Michelangelo
you know it when you see it
and the opposite of that is code that is
messy code that smells you know when you
see it and I'm not sure you can describe
it in words except vaguely through
guidelines and so on yes it's easier to
recognize ugly than to recognize beauty
in code and for the reason is that
sometimes beauty comes from something
that's innovative and unusual and you
have to sometimes think reasonably hard
to appreciate that
on the other hand the misses have things
in common and you can you can have
static checkers dynamic checkers that
finds large number of the most common
mistakes you can catch a lot of
sloppiness mechanically I'm a great fan
of static analysis in particular because
you can check for not just the language
rules but for the usage of language
rules and I think we will see much more
static analysis in the coming decade
clear the drive word static analysis you
represent a piece of code so that you
can write a program that goes or that
representation and look for things that
are right and not right so for instance
you can analyze a program to see if
resources are leaked that's one of my
favorite problems it's not actually all
that hard and one C++ but you can do it
if you were writing in the C level you
have to have a Murloc and a free and
they have to match if you have them in a
single function you can usually do it
very easily if there's a man log here
there should be a free there on the
other hand in between can be drawing
complete code and then it becomes
impossible yeah if you pass that pointer
to the memory out of a function and then
want to make sure that the free is done
somewhere else now it gets really
difficult and so for static analysis you
can run through a program and you can
try and figure out if there's any leaks
and what you will properly find is that
you will find some leaks and you'll find
quite a few places where your analysis
can't be complete it might depend on
runtime it might
depend on the cleverness of your
analyzer and it might take a long time
some of these programs run for a long
time but if you combine such analysis
with a set of rules it says how people
could use it you can actually see why
the rules are violated and that stops
you from getting into the impossible
complexities you don't want to solve the
halting problem the static analysis is
looking at the code without running the
code yes and thereby it's almost not in
production code but it's almost like an
educational tool of how the language
should be used it's guys you like it is
best right it would guide you in how you
write future code as well and you learn
together yes so basically you need a set
of rules for how you use the language
then you need a static analysis that
catches your mistakes when you violate
the rules or when your code ends up
doing things that it shouldn't despite
the rules because there's the language
rules you can go further and again it's
back to my idea that I would much rather
find errors before I start running the
code if nothing else once the code runs
if it catches an error at run times I
have to have an error handler and one of
the hardest things to write in code is
their handling code because you know
something went wrong
do you know really exactly what went
wrong usually not how can you recover
when you don't know what the problem was
you can't be a hundred percent sure what
the problem was in many many cases and
this is this is part of it so yes we
need good languages or good type systems
we need rules for how to use them we
need static analysis and the ultimate
for static analysis is of course program
proof but that still doesn't scale so
the kind of systems we deploy
then we start needing testing and the
rest of the stuff so C++ is an
object-oriented programming language
that creates especially with its newer
versions as we'll talk about higher and
higher levels of abstraction so how do
you design let's even go back to the
origin C++ how you design something with
so much abstraction that's still
efficient and is still something that
you can manage do static analysis on you
can have constraints on they can be
reliable those things we've talked about
so create the to me slightly there's a
slight tension between high-level
abstraction and efficiency that's a good
question I could probably have a year's
course just trying to answer it yes
there's a tension between efficiency and
abstraction but you also get the
interesting situation that you get the
best efficiency out of the best
abstraction and my main tool for
efficiency for performance actually is
abstraction so let's go back to how C++
got there yeah you said it was up to
Rory in the programming language I
actually never said that it's always
quoted but I never did I said C++
supports object-oriented programming but
it's nine other techniques and that
that's important because I think that
the best solution to most complex
interesting problems require ideas and
techniques from things that has been
called object-oriented data abstraction
function or traditional C style code all
of the above and so when I was designing
C++ I soon realized I couldn't just add
features
if you just add what looks pretty or
what people ask for or what you think is
good one by one you're not going to get
a coherent whole what you need is a set
of guidelines that that that guides your
decisions should this feature Vienna
should this feature be out how should a
feature be modified before it can go in
and such and there's a in in the book I
wrote about that that sign evolution of
si+ process a whole bunch of rules like
that most of them are not language
technical they they they're they're
things like don't violate static type
system because I like static type system
for the obvious reason that I like
things to be reliable on reasonable
amounts of hardware
but one of these rules is the zero
overhead principle the were kind of put
a zero overhead principle it basically
says that if you have an abstraction it
should not cost anything compared to
write the equivalent code at a lower
level so if I have say a matrix
multiplied it should be written in such
a way that you could not drop to the C
level of abstraction and use arrays and
pointers and such and run faster and so
people have written such matrix
multiplications and we have actually
gotten code that ran faster than Fortran
because once you had the right
abstraction you can eliminate you can
eliminate temporaries and you can do
loop fusion and other good stuff like
that that's quite hard to do by hand and
in a lower level language and there's
some really nice examples of that and
the key here is that that matrix
multiplication the matrix abstraction
allows you to write code that's simple
and easy you can do that in any language
but with C++ it has the features so that
you can also have this thing run faster
than if you hand coded it now people
have given that lecture many times I and
others and a very common on question
after the talk where you have
demonstrated that you can outperform
Fortran for dense matrix multiplication
people come up and says yeah but there
are C++ if I rewrote your code and see
how much faster would have run the
answer is much slower this happened the
first time actually back in the ages
with a friend of mine called Doug
McIlroy who demonstrated exactly this
effect and so the principle is you
should give programmers the tools so
that the abstractions can follow the 0oi
principle
furthermore when you put in a language
feature in C++ or a standard library
feature you try to meet this it doesn't
mean it's absolutely optimal but it
means if you're hand coded with the
usual the facilities in the language in
C++ in C you should not be able to
better it usually you can do better if
you use embedded a simpler for machine
code for some of the details to utilize
part of a computer that the compiler
doesn't know about but you should get to
that point before you be to the
abstraction so that's that's a beautiful
ideal to reach for and we meet it quite
often quite often so where's the magic
of that coming from there's some of it
is the compilation process so the
implementation is C++ some of it is the
design of the feature itself the
guidelines so I've recently an often
talk of Chris Ladner so clang what just
out of curiosity is your relationship in
general with the different
implementations in C++ as you think
about you and committee and other people
C++ think about the design of new
features or design of previous features
the in in trying to reach the ideal of
zero overhead who does the magic come
from the design the guidelines or from
the implementations and and not all you
have you you are you you you you go for
programming technique program language
features and implementation techniques
you need all three and how can you think
about all three at the same time it
takes some experience takes some
practice and sometimes you get it wrong
but after a while you sort of get it
right I don't write compilers anymore
but
Brian Kearney and pointed out that one
of the reason c++ succeeded was some of
the craftsmanship I put into the early
compilers and of course I did the
languages sign of course I wrote a fair
amount of code using this kind of stuff
and I think most of the successes
involves progress in all three areas
together a small group of people can do
that two three people can can work
together to do something like that it's
ideal if it's one person that has all
the skills necessary but nobody has all
the skills necessary in all the fields
where C++ is used so if you want to
approach my idea in say concurrent
programming you need to know about
algorithms of my current programming you
need to know the the triggering of
lock-free programming you need to know
something about compiler techniques and
then you have to know some of the
program error the sorry the application
areas what this is like some forms of
graphics or some forms of what are
called the web server and kind of stuff
and that's very hard to get into a
single head but small groups can do it
too it says there differences in your
view not saying which is better or so on
but difference in the different
implementations of C++ why are there
several sort of many of you naive
questions for me
GCC clang so this is a very reasonable
question when I designed C++
most languages have multiple
implementations because if you wanna I
p.m. if you run on a Sun if you wanna
Motorola that those just many many
companies and they each have their own
compilation structure the old compilers
it was just fairly common that those
many of them and I wrote C front
assuming that other people would write
compilers for C++ if I was successful
and furthermore I wanted to utilize all
the backend infrastructure were
available I soon realized that my users
were using 25 different linkers I
couldn't write my own linker yes I could
but I couldn't write 25 linkers and also
get any work done on the language and so
it came from a world where there was
many linkers many optimizers many
compiler front ends not not to start but
over at many operating systems the whole
world was not an 86 and linux box or
something whatever is the standard today
in the old days they said a set of X so
basically I assumed there'd be lots of
compilers it was not a decision that
there should be many compilers it was
just a fact that's the way the world is
and yes many compilers emerged and today
there's at least four front ends playing
GCC Microsoft and EDG it is Design Group
they they supply a lot of the
independence organizations and the
embedded systems industry and there's
lots and lots of backends we have to
think about how many dozen begins there
are because different machines have
different things especially in the
embedded world their machines are very
different the architectures are very
different
and so having a single implementation
was never an option
now I also happen to dislike
monocultures monocultures they are
dangerous because whoever owns the
monoculture can go stale and there's no
competition and there's no incentive to
innovate there's a lot of incentive to
put barriers in the way of change
because hey we own the world and it's a
very comfortable world for us and who
are you to to mess with that so I really
am very happy that this for front-ends
for C++ clanks great but GCC was great
but then it got somewhat stale Tran came
along and GCC's much better now
competition my Microsoft is much better
now
so hello at least a low number our front
end puts a lot of pressure on
stand-ups compliance and also on
performance and error messages and
compile time speed all this good stuff
that we want do you think crazy question
there might come along you hope that
might come along implementation of C++
written given all its history written
from scratch so written today from
scratch well playing and the LLVM this
more less written by from scratch but
there's been c++ 11 14 17 20 you know
there's been a lot you know later
somebody's going to try again there has
been attempts to write new C++ compilers
and some of them has been used and some
of them has been absorbed into others
and so yeah I don't happen so what are
the key features of C++ and let's use
that as a way to sort of talk about the
evolution of C++ the new feature so at
the highest level what are the features
that were there in the beginning what
features got added its first get a
principal on aim in place C++ is for
people who want to use hardware really
well and then manage the complexity of
doing that through abstraction and so
the first facility you you have is a way
of manipulating the machines at a fairly
low level that looks very much like see
it has loops it has variables it has
pointers like machine addresses it can
access memory directly it can allocate
stuff in the absolute minimum of space
needed on the machine there's a machine
facing part of C++ which is roughly
equivalent to C I said C++ could beat C
and it can doesn't mean I dislike see if
I disliked C
wouldn't have built on it furthermore
after Dennis Ritchie I'm probably the
major contributor to modern C and well I
had lunch with Dennis most days for 16
years and we never had a harsh word
between us so these C versus C++ fights
are for people who don't quite
understand what's going on then the
other part is the abstraction and there
the key is the class which is a user
defined type and my idea for the class
is that you should be able to build a
type that's just like the building types
in in the way you use them in the way
you declare them and the way you get the
memory and you can do just as well
so in C++ there's an int as in C you
should be able to build an abstraction a
class which we can call capital int that
you could use exactly like an integer
and run just as fast as an integer
there's the idea right there and of
course you probably don't want to use
the int itself but it has happened
people have wanted integers that were
range checked so that you couldn't
overflow one such especially for very
safety critical applications like the
fuel injection for a marine diesel
engine for the largest ships this is a
real example by the way this has been
done they they built themselves an
integer that was just like integer
except that couldn't overflow if there's
no or flow you went into the error
handling and then you built more
interesting types you can build a matrix
which you need to do graphics or you
could build a gnome for a for a video
game and all these are classes and they
appear just like the built-in types
exciting terms of efficiency and so on
so what else is there and flexibility so
I don't know for people who are not
familiar with object-oriented
programming
there's inheritance there's a hierarchy
of classes you you can just like you
said create a generic vehicle that can
turn left so what people found was that
you don't actually know how do I say
this
a lot of types are related that is the
vehicles all the accounts are related
bicycles cars fire engines tanks they
have some things in common and some
things that differ and you would like to
have the common things common and having
the differences specific and when you
didn't want to know about the
differences like just turn left
uuuuu you don't have to worry about it
that's how you get the traditional
object-oriented programming coming out
of simulate opted by small talk and C++
and all the other languages the other
kind of obvious similarity between types
comes when you have something like a
vector fortune gave us the vector as
called array of doubles but the minute
you have a vector of doubles you want a
vector or double precision doubles and
for short doubles for graphics and why
should you have not have a vector of
integers while you're added or vector of
vectors and vector of vectors of chess
pieces now we have a board right so this
is you express array the commonality as
the idea of a vector and the variations
come through parameterization and so
here we get the two fundamental ways of
abstracting or of having similarities of
types in C++
there's the inheritance and there's a
parameterization
there's the object-oriented programming
in this generic programming
with the templates for the generic
program yeah so you you've presented it
very nicely but now you have to make all
that happen and make it efficient so
generic programming with templates
there's all kinds of magic going on
especially recently that you can help
catch up on but it feels to me like you
can do way more than what you just said
with templates you can start doing this
kind of meta programming this kind you
can do meta programming also I I didn't
go there and in that explanation we're
trying to be very basics but go back on
so the implementation implementation if
you couldn't implement this efficiently
if you couldn't use it so that it became
efficient it has no place in C++ because
it were violates the zero overhead
principle so when I had to get up during
programming inheritance I took the idea
of virtual functions from Simula virtual
functions is a similar term class is a
similar term if you ever use those words
say thanks to question you go and all
you and I'll and I did the simplest
implementation I knew off which was
basically a jump table so you get the
virtual function table or the function
goes in do it does an indirection
through a table and get the right
function that's how you pick the right
thing there and I thought that was
trivial it's close to optimal it's endo
is obvious it turned out the Simula had
a more complicated way of doing it
therefore slower and it turns out that
most languages have something that's a
little bit more complicated sometimes
more flexible but you pay for it and one
of the strengths of C++ was that you
could actually do this object-oriented
stuff and your overhead compared to
ordinary functions there's no
interactions it's not open five ten
twenty five percent for just the core it
sits down there it's not too
and that means you can afford to use it
furthermore in C++ you have the
distinction between a virtual function
and a non-virtual function if you don't
want any overhead if you don't need the
interaction that gives you the
flexibility in object-oriented
programming just don't ask for it so the
idea is that you only use virtual
functions if you actually need the
flexibility so it's not zero overhead
but zero overhead compared to any other
way of achieving the flexibility now
also parameterization basically the
compiler looks at at the the template
say the vector and it looks at the
parameter and then combines the two and
generates a piece of code that is
exactly as if you're written a vector
off that specific type yes so that's the
that's the minimal overhead if you have
many template parameters you can
actually combine code that the compiler
couldn't usually see at the same time
and therefore get code that is faster
then if you had handwritten stuff on
this you are very very clever so the
thing is Parature i's code the compiler
fills stuff in during the compilation
process not during runtime that's right
and so in furthermore it gives all the
information it's gotten which is the
template the parameter and the context
of use it combines the three and
generates good code but it can generate
now it's a little outside of what I'm
even comfortable thinking about but it
can generate a lot of code yes and how
do you remember being both amazed at the
power of that idea and how ugly the
debugging look
the debugging can be truly horrid come
back to this because I have a solution
anyway
the debugging was ugly the code
generated by C++ has always been ugly
because there's these inherent
optimizations a modern C++ compiler has
runned in middle-end and beckoned
optimizations even C front back in 83
had front end and back end optimizations
I actually took the code generated an
internal representation munch that
implements a representation to generate
good code so people says it's not a
compiler I generate see if the reason it
generated C was a one that you used to
C's code generators that are really good
at backend optimizations but I need a
front end of two eyes Asians and
therefore the C I generated was
optimized C hmm the way really good up a
handcrafted optimize a human who could
could generate it and it was not meant
for humans it was the output of a
program and it's much worse today and
with templates it gets much worse still
so it's hard to do it's hard to combine
simple debugging with simple with the
optimal code because the idea is to drag
in information from different parts of
the code to generate good code machine
code and that's not readable so what
people often do for debugging is they
turn the optimizer off and so you get
code that when you when when something
in your source code looks like a
function call it is a function call when
the optimizer is turned on it may
disappear the function call it may
inline and so one of the things you can
do is you can actually get code that is
smaller than the function call because
you eliminate the function preamble and
returned and that's just the operation
there one of the key things when I did
templates was I wanted to make sure that
if you have say a sort algorithm and you
give it a sorting criteria if that
sorting criteria is simply comparing
things with lesson
the code generators should be the less
than not a indirect function call to a
compression object which is what it is
in the source code but we really want
down to the single instruction and but
anyway turn off the optimizer and and
you can you can debug the first level of
debugging can be done and I always do
without the optimization on because then
I can see what's going on and then
there's this idea of concepts that puts
some now I've never even the I don't
know if it was ever available in any
form but it puts some constraints on the
stuff you can parameterize essentially
let me try and explain yes so yes it
wasn't there ten years ago we have had
versions of it that actually work for
the last four or five years it was a
design by Gabby does raise true certain
and me we were professors and postdocs
in Texas at the time and the
implementation by Andrew Sutton has been
available for at that time and it is
part of C++ 20 and the standard library
that uses it so this is becoming really
very real it's available in clang and
GCC GCC for a couple of years and I
believe Microsoft zum-zum going to
do it expect a wall of C++ 20 to be
available so in all the major compilers
in 20 but this kind of stuff is it's
available now I'm just saying that
because otherwise people might think I
was talking about science fiction and so
what I'm going to say Israel on Crete
you can write it today
and there's production users of it so
the basic idea is that when you have a a
generic component like a sort function
the sort function will will require at
least two parameters one a data
structure with a given type and
comparison criteria and these things are
related but obviously you can't compare
things if you don't know what the type
of things you compare
and so you want to be able to say I'm
going to sort something and did this to
be sortable what does it mean to be
sortable you look it up in the standard
it has to have it has to be a sequence
with a beginning and an end there has to
be random access to that sequence and
there has to be the element types has to
be comparable like you more like an
operator can I do it yes what illogical
already cannot basically what concepts
are there compile-time predicates there
predicates you can ask are you a
sequence yes I have begin an end
are you a random exit sequence yes I
have subscripting and plus it's your
element type something that has a less
then yes I have a less than hits and so
basically that's the system and so
instead of saying I will take a
parameter of any type it'll say I'll
take something that's audible and it's
well defined and so we say okay you can
sorta less then I don't want less then I
want greater then also something I
invent so you have two parameters the
sortable thing and the compassion
criteria and the comparison criteria
will say well I can you you can write it
saying it should operate on the element
type and it has the compassion
operations so that's the simply the
fundamental thing it's compile-time
predicates do you have the properties I
need so it specifies the requirements of
the code on the parameters that gets yes
there are lots of types actually but
operating in the space of concepts
concepts the word concept was used by
Alec Stephan of who is sort of the
father of generic programming in the
context of C++
there's other places that use that word
but the way we call Genetic Programming
is Alex's and he called them concepts
because he said there they are the sort
of the fundamental concepts of an area
so they should be called concepts and
we've had concepts all the time if you
look at the knr book about si si has
arithmetic types and it has integral
types it says so in the book and then it
lists what they are and they have
certain properties the difference today
is that we can actually write a concept
that will ask a type are you an integral
type do you have the properties
necessary to be an integral type do you
have Proust - divide so what may be the
story of concepts because I thought it
might be part of C++ 11 C C C's o X or
whatever it was at the time what was the
why didn't it look like what we'll talk
a little bit about this fascinating
process of standards because I think
it's really interesting for people it's
interesting for me but why did it take
so long what shapes the the idea of
concepts take what were the challenges
back in 87 of there abouts 97 well 1987
like they are about so when I was
designing templates obviously I wanted
to express the notion of what is
required by a template of its arguments
and so I looked at this and basically
for for templates I wanted three
properties I wanted to be very flexible
it had to be able to express things I
couldn't imagine because I know I can't
imagine everything and I've been
suffering from languages and try to
constrain you to only do what you're the
designer thought good didn't want to do
that
secondly it had to run faster
as faster faster that hand written code
so basically if I have a vector of T and
I take a vector of cha it should run as
fast as you built a vector of cha
yourself without parameterization and
second and thirdly I wanted to be able
to express the constraints of of the
arguments have proper type checking of
the interfaces and neither I nor anybody
else at the time knew how to get all
three and I thought for C++ I must have
the two first otherwise it's not C++ and
it bothered me for an hour a couple of
decades that I couldn't solve the third
one I mean I was the one that put
function argument type checking in to
see I know the value of good interfaces
I didn't invent that idea it's very
common but I did it and I wanted to do
the same for templates of course and I
could so it bothered me then we try it
again
mm of to 2003
cavitus raised and I started analyzing
the problem explained possible solutions
there was not a complete design a group
in University of Indiana an old friend
of mine they started a project at
Indiana and we thought we could get a
good system of concepts in another two
or three years that would have made C++
la 11 to C++ Oh 607 well it turns out
that I think we got a lot of the
fundamental ideas are wrong they were
took on conventional they didn't quite
fit C++ in my opinion didn't serve
implicit conversions very well it didn't
of mixed makes type arithmetic mix type
computation computations very well a lot
of stuff came out of the functional
community and it that community didn't
deal with multiple types in in the same
way as C++ does had more constraints on
on what you could express and didn't
have the draconian performance
requirements and basically we tried we
tried very hard we had some successes
but it just in the end wasn't didn't
compile fast enough was too hard to use
and didn't run fast enough unless you
had optimizes that was beyond the state
of the art they still are so we had to
do something else basically it was the
idea that a set of parameters has
defines a set of operations and you go
through an interaction table just like
for virtual functions and then you try
to optimize the interaction away to get
performance and we just couldn't do all
of that but get back to the
standardization we are standardizing C++
on the ISO rules which a very open
process people come in there's no
requirements for education or experience
they start develop C++ and there's a
hope when was the first standard
established what is that like the ISO
standard is there committee that you're
referring to she was a group of people
what it was that like how often do you
meet what's the disguise I'll try and
explain that so sometime in early 1989
two people one from IBM one from HP
turned up in my office and told me I
would like to standardize it PLAs PLAs
this was a new idea to me and I pointed
out that it wasn't finished yet it
wasn't ready for former standardization
and such and they say no beyond even
gotten it you you really want to do this
our organizations depend on c++ we
cannot depend on something that's owned
by another corporation that might be a
competitor of course we could rely on
you
but you might get run over by a bus
right the old really needs to get this
out new it has to be standardized under
formal rules and we are going to
standardize it under ISO rules and you
really want to be part of it because
basically otherwise we will do it
ourselves and we know you can do it
better so through a combination of
arm-twisting and flattery
Carolus started so in late
in late 89 there was a meeting in DC at
the x-ray no it was not ISO then it was
an SI the American national standard
were doing
we met there we were lectured on the
rules of how to do when ANSI standard
there was about 25 of us there which
apparently was a new record for that
kind of meeting and some of the old see
guys that it's been standardizing see
was there so we got some expertise in so
the way this works is that it's an open
process
anybody can consign up if they pay the
minimal fee which is about a thousand
dollars still less then just a little
bit more now and I think it's twelve
hundred and eighty dollars it's not it's
not going to kill you
and we have three meetings a year this
is fairly standard
we try to meetings a year for a couple
years that didn't work too well so three
weeks is three one-week meetings a year
and you meet and you have taken meet
technical discussions and then you bring
proposals forward for votes the votes
are done one person per one vote per
organization so you can't have say IBM
come in with 10 people and dominate
things that's not allowed and these
organizations that extends to the UC bus
bus this yes this is all individuals or
individuals I mean it's a it's a bunch
of people in room deciding the design of
a language based on which a lot of the
world's systems run right well I think
most people would agree it's better than
if I decided it or better than if a
single organization like agency decides
it I don't know if everyone agrees to
that by the way bureaucracies have their
critics - yes they they're that look
standardization is not pleasant it's
it's it's horrifying like democracy what
we exactly as Churchill says democracy
is the worst way except for or the
others right and it's about say the same
reforms
but anyway so we meet and we we have
these votes and that determines what the
standard is couple of years later we
extended this so it became worldwide we
have stand out of organizations that are
active in currently 15 to 20 countries
and another
fifteen to twenty are sort of looking
and and voting based on the rest of the
work on it and we meet three times a
year next week I'll be in Cologne
Germany spending a week doing
standardization and we'll vote out the
committee draft or c plus plus 20 which
goes to the national standards
committees for comments and requests for
changes and improvements then we do that
and there's a second set of votes where
hopefully everybody votes in favor this
has happened several times the first
time we finished we started in the first
technical meeting was in 1990 the last
was in 98 we voted it out that was
suspended that people used till 11:00 or
a little bit past 11:00 and was an
international standard all the countries
voted in favor it took longer with 11
I'll mention why what all the nations
voted in favor and we work on the basis
of consensus that is we do not want
something that passes 6040 because then
we're going to get dialects and
opponents and people complain too much
they don't complain so much but
basically it no real effect the the
standards has been obeyed they have been
working to make it easier to use many
compilers many computers and all of that
kind of stuff and so the first the
traditional with ISO standards to take
ten years we did the first one and eight
brilliant and we thought we were going
to do the next one and six because now
we're good at it right it took 13 yeah
it was named Oh X he was named Oh X
hoping that you would at least get it in
within the single within the arts the
single day I thought we would get yeah I
thought would gets
six seven or eight the confidence of
youth yes right well the point is that
this was sort of like a second system
effect that is we now knew how to do it
and so we're going to do it much better
and we got more ambitious and bish han
dicho penguia furthermore there is this
tendency because it's a 10-year cycle or
age doesn't matter just before you're
out to ship somebody has a bright idea
yeah and so we really really must get
that in we did that successfully with
the STL we got the the standard Liars
all the STL stuff that that my base be I
think it saved C++ it was beautiful
yes and then people tried it with all
our things and it didn't work so well
they got things in but it wasn't as
dramatic and it took longer and longer
and longer
so after C++ 11 which was a huge
improvement and what basically what most
people are using today we decided ever
again
and so how do you avoid those slips and
the answer is that you shipped more
often so that if you if you if you have
a slip on the 10-year cycle by the time
you know it's a slip there's 11 years
till you get it yeah now with a three
year cycle there is about three or four
years till you get it like the delay
between feature freeze and shipping so
you always get one or two years more and
so we were shipped fourteen on time we
shipped seventeen on time and we ship we
will ship 20 on time
it's it'll happen and furthermore this
allow this gives a predictability that
allows the implementers the compiler
implementers the library implementers so
they have a target and they deliver on
it 11 took two years before most
compilers were good enough 14 most
compilers were actually getting pretty
good in 14 17 everybody shipped in 17
well we are going to have at least
almost everybody's ship almost
everything in 20 and I know this because
they're shipping in nineteen predictably
this is good delivery on time is good
and so yeah that's great those how it
works there's a lot of features that
came in in C++ 11 there's a lot of
features at the birth of C++ they were
amazing and ideas with concepts in 2020
what to you is the most justjust to you
personally beautiful or just you sit
back and think wow that's just nice and
clean feature of C++ I have written two
papers for the history of programming
languages conference which basically
asked me such questions
and I'm writing a third one which I will
deliver at the history of programming
languages conference in London next year
so I've been thinking about that and
there is one play answer constructors
and destructors the way a constructor
can establish the environment for the
use of the Java type for object and the
destructor that cleans up any messes at
the end of it that is the key to C++
that's why we don't have to use garbage
collection that's how we can get
predictable performance that's how you
can get the minimal overhead in many
many cases and have really clean types
it's the idea of constructor destructor
pairs sometimes it comes out under the
name our high AIII resource acquisition
is initialization which is the idea that
you grab resources and the constructor
and release them and destructor it's
also the best example of why I shouldn't
be in advertising I get the best idea
and I call it resource acquisition is
initialization not the greatest naming
I've ever heard so it's types
abstraction of types you said I want to
create my own types so types is an
essential part of C++ and making them
efficient as the if it is the key part
and GU the this is almost getting
philosophical but the construction and
the destruction the creation of an
instance of a type and the freeing of
resources from that instance of a type
is what defines the object is uh that's
like birth and death is what defines
human life yeah that's right
by the way philosophy is important you
can't do good language design without
philosophy because what you are
determining is what people can express
this is very important by the way
constructors destructors came into C++
in 79 in about the second week of my
work with what was then Corsi of the
classes
it is a fundamental idea next comes the
fact that you need to control copying
because once you control as you says
birth and death you have to control
taking copies which is another way of
creating an object and finally you have
to be able to move things around so you
get the move operations and that's the
set of key operations you can define on
a C++ type inserts you those things are
just a beautiful part of C++ that is at
the core of it all yes you mentioned
that you hope there will be one unified
set of guidelines in the future for how
to construct the programming language so
perhaps not one programming language but
a unification of how we build
programming languages if you remember
the statement I I have some trouble
remembering it but I know the origin of
that idea so maybe you can talk about
sort of C++ has been improving there's
been a lot of programming language do
you word is the arc of history taking us
do you hope that there is a unification
about the languages with which we
communicate in the digital space well
III think that languages should be
designed not by clobbering language
features together and doing slightly
different versions or somebody else's
ideas but through the creation of a set
of principles rules of thumbs whatever
you call them I I made them for C++ and
we're trying to teach people in the
Standards Committee about these rules
because a lot of people come in and says
I've got a great idea let's put it in
language
and then you have to ask why does it fit
in the language why does it fit in this
language it may fit in on our language
and not here
or may fit here not the other language
so you have to work from a set of
principles and you have to develop that
set of principles and it's one example
that I sometimes remember is I was
sitting down with some of the designers
of common lisp and we are talking about
languages and language features and
obviously we didn't agree about anything
because well this was not C++ and vice
versa
too many parenthesis but suddenly we
started making progress I said I had
this problem and I developed it
according to these ideas and they said
what why we had that problem different
problem and we develop it the same kind
of principles and so we worked through
large chunks of C++ and large chunks of
Common Lisp and figure out we actually
had similar sets of principles of how to
do it but the constraints on our designs
were very different and the aims for the
usage was very different but there was
commonality in the way you reason about
language features and the fundamental
principles you are trying to do so do
you think that's possible to so they're
just like there is perhaps a unified
theory of physics of the fundamental
forces of physics now I'm sure there is
commonalities among the languages but
there's also people involved you know
that help drive these developing these
languages do you have a hope or an
optimism that there will be a
unification if you think about physics
and Einstein towards a simplified
language do you think that it's possible
let's remember sort of modern physics I
think started with Galileo in the 1300s
so they have had seven hundred years to
get going
modern computing started in about 49
we've got what's that 70 years they have
10 10 times yeah
and furthermore they they are not as
bothered with people using physics the
way we are worried about programming
it's done by humans so each have
problems and constraints the others have
but we are very immature compared to
physics so I would look at sort of the
philosophical level and and look for
fundamental principles like you don't
leak resources you shouldn't you don't
take errors at runtime that you don't
need to you don't violate some kind of
type system there's many kinds of type
systems but when you have one you don't
break it
etc etc there will be quite a few and it
will not be be the same for all
languages but I think if we step back at
some kind of philosophical level we can
we would be able to agree on sets of
principles that applied to two sets of
problem areas and within an area of use
by in C++ this case what used to be
called systems programming the area
between the hardware and the the the
fluffier parts of the system you you
might very well see a convergence so
these days you see rust having a adopted
ra íí- and sometime accuses me for
having borrowed it 20 years before they
discovered it but it's
we're seeing some kind of conversion
convergence here instead of relying on
garbage collection all the time the
garbage collection languages are doing
things like the dispose patterns and
such that imitates some of the
construction destruction stuff and
they're trying not to use the garbage
collection all the time things like that
so there's there there's conversion but
I think we have to step back to the
philosophical level and agree on
principles and then we'll see some
conversions convergences and it will be
application domain-specific so a crazy
question but I work a lot with machine
learning with deep learning I'm not sure
if you touch that world that much but
you could think of programming is the
thing that takes some input programming
is the task of creating a program and a
program takes some input and produces
some output so machine learning systems
train on data in order to be able to
take an input and produce output but
they're messy fuzzy things much like we
as children grow up you know we take
some input make some output but we're
noisy we mess up a lot we're definitely
not reliable biological system or a
giant mess so there's a sense in which
machine learning is a kind of way of
programming but just fuzzy it's very
very very different than C++ because C++
is a like it's just like you said it's
extremely reliable it's efficient it's
you know you can you can measure you can
test in a bunch of different ways with
biological systems or machine learning
systems you can't say much except sort
of empirically saying that ninety-nine
point eight percent of the time it seems
to work what do you think about this
fuzzy kind of programming indeed even
see it as programming is it solely and
totally another kind of world I
I think it's a different kind of world
and it is fuzzy and in my domain I don't
like fuzziness that is people say things
like they want everybody to be able to
program but I don't want everybody to
program my my aeroplane controls or the
car controls I want that to be done by
engineers I want that to be done with
people that are specifically educated
and trained for doing building things
and it is not for everybody
similarly a language like C++ is not for
everybody it is generated via sharp and
effective tool for professionals
basically and definitely for people who
who aim at some kind of precision you
don't have people doing calculations
without understanding math right
counting on your fingers not going to
cut it if you want to fly to the moon
and so there are areas where and
eighty-four percent accuracy rate 16
percent false positive rate it's
perfectly acceptable and where people
will probably get no more than 70 you
said 98% I what I have seen is more like
84 and by by really a lot of blood sweat
and tears you can get up to the 92 and a
half right so this is fine if it is say
pre-screening stuff before the human
look at it it is not good enough for for
life-threatening situations and so
there's lots of areas where where the
fuzziness is perfectly acceptable and
good and better than humans cheaper than
humans but it's not the kind of
engineering stuff I'm mostly interested
in
I worry a bit about machine learning
the context of cars you know much more
about this than I do I worry too but I'm
I'm sort of a an amateur here I've read
some of the papers but I have not ever
done it and the the idea that scares me
the most is the one I have heard and I
don't know how common it is that you
have this AI system machine learning all
of these trained neural nets and when
they're something is too complicated
they asked the human for help but human
is reading a book or sleep and he has 30
seconds or three seconds to figure out
what the problem was that the AI system
couldn't handle and do the right thing
this is scary
I mean how do you do the cutter walk
between the Machine and the human it's
very very difficult and for the designer
or one of the most reliable efficient
and powerful programming languages C++ I
can understand why that world is
actually unappealing it is for most
engineers to me it's extremely appealing
because we don't know how to get that
interaction right but I think it's
possible but it's very very hard it is
and I was stating a problem no yes that
is the nostril I mean I would much
rather never rely on a human if you're
driving a nuclear reactor if you're or
an autonomous vehicle it would it's much
better to design systems written in C++
that never asked human for help let's
just get one fact in yeah all of this AI
star Suns help us constructs so so
that's one reason I have to keep a
weather eye out or what's going on in
that field but I will never become an
expert
area but it's a good example of how you
separate different areas of applications
and you have to have different tools
different principles and then they
interact no major system today is
written in one language and there are
good reasons for that when you look back
at your life work what is uh what is the
moment what is a event creation that
you're really proud of
they say damn I did pretty good there is
it as obvious as the creation of C++ and
so obvious I've spent a lot of time with
C++ and there's a combination of a few
good ideas a lot of hard work and a bit
of luck and I try to get away from it a
few times but I get tracked in again
partly because I'm most effective in
this area and partly because what I do
has much more impact if I do it in the
context of C++ I I have four and a half
million people that pick it up tomorrow
if I get something right if I did it in
another field I would have to start
learning then I have to build it and
then or see if anybody wants to use it
one of the things that has kept me going
for all of these years is one the good
things that people do with it and the
interesting things they do with it and
also I get to see a lot of interesting
stuff and talk to a lot of interesting
people I mean if it has just been
statements on paper on a screen I I
don't think I could have kept going but
I get to see the telescopes up on Mauna
Kea and I actually went and see how Ford
built cars and I got to JPL and see how
they do the the Mars rovers there's so
much cool stuff going on and most of the
cool stuff is done by pretty nice people
and sometimes in very nice places
cambridge sophia antipolis silicon
valley
yeah it's there there's more to it than
just code but code is central on top of
the code are the people in very nice
places well I think I speak for millions
of people we aren't in saying thank you
for creating this language that so many
systems are built on top of them that
make a better world so thank you and
thank you for talking today yeah thanks
and we'll make it even better good
you